PAS allocated a private
IP address by default and
cannot be reached
outside of the cluster.
I used a kubectl port-forward
command to map a local port
to a port inside the monolith pod.
Use two terminals.
One to run the kubectl
port-forward command and
the other to issue kernel commands.
Now in our new terminal we'll
start talking to our pod.
Okay.
Let's see what happens when
we hit the secure end point.
Uh-oh, let's try logging in to get
it off token back from our monolith.
I'll use the super secret
password password as my password.
We'll use the JWT token from the output
to hit our secure endpoint and
it works and
everything is good in the world again.
Here is the kubectl logs command to
view the logs for the monolith pod.
Let's open another terminal and
use the -f flag to get a stream
of logs happening in real time.
And as you can see,
the logs are updating in real time.
We can use kubectl exec command
to run an interactive show
inside the model of POD.
This come in handy when you want
troubleshoot from within the container.
For example, once we have a shell
into the mile of container we
can test external connectivity
using the ping command.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Then when you're done with the
interactive show, be sure to log out.
As you can see, interacting with PAS is
as easy as using the kubectl command,
whether you're trying to hit
your containers remotely or
trying to get a log in shell for
troubleshooting.
Cooper Nades provides everything
you need to get up and going.